nous connaissons la France des Lumières
avec vous nous aurons la France des
bougies
la circulaire que vous avez adressée au
préfet pour qu'ils se préparent à
d'éventuelles coupures programmées de
l'électricité scandalise nos concitoyens
ces coupures renommés pudiquement
délestage concernerait 60% des Français
sans faire la distinction entre des
domiciles vides et des deux logements de
personnes âgées dépendantes ou de
famille avec des enfants en bas âge les
trains métro out pourront être
interrompus empêchant nos concitoyens
d'aller au travail des écoles fermées
pour ne pas risquer de se retrouver sans
chauffage ni lumière ni à l'arme
obligeant les parents à rester chez eux
comment notre pays peut-il se retrouver
dans cette situation et pourtant nous
pensions avoir tout vu avec votre
gestion calamiteuse de la crise covid
j'ai rencontré des citoyens en colère
dans mon département des Ardennes ce
week-end parce que les télés alarmes les
téléphones fixes ne fonctionneront plus
parce que sans leur appareil médicaux
connectés les personnes hospitalisées à
domicile seront en danger en effet le
préfet ne pourra pas isoler un logement
dans une zone coupée concrètement
avez-vous pensé au millier de personnes
sous assistance respiratoires au porteur
d'un cœur artificiel qui doivent
recharger leur batterie à nos
concitoyens branchés à des pousses
seringues qui ne peuvent se passer
d'électricité sans compter les dialysés
à domicile nos concitoyens doivent-ils
investir dans des groupes électrogènes
en urgence madame la Première ministre
la guerre en Ukraine à Bondo ce sont en
réalité dix années 10 années de gestion
Hollande Macron qui sont la cause de
cette situation inacceptable dans un
pays comme le nôtre madame la Première
ministre assumez vos erreurs et trouver
des solutions concrètes sans mettre nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles en danger